welcome to a preview where we're going
to talk about the brand new expansion
for card hunter attack of the artifacts
taykitty artifacts is the first
expansion for the game since we launched
last year and it contains a whole bunch
of new stuff I'm just gonna give you a
little bit of an overview in this video
and then we're gonna do some videos over
the next few days we were going to show
you some of the content and a little bit
more detail so what does this expansion
set contain well for a start there are
six new adventures these adventures
split into two groups one of them is a
levels at level seven eight and nine
adventures so they're around the middle
of the campaign and they're pretty good
to play through if maybe you got stuck
halfway through the campaign and need a
little bit of a helping hand and you
just want to explore some new content
the value of tes Cal is the first one of
these mid-level adventures and it's a
new adventure path which takes you
through a mysterious Valley which has
appeared in the east of card hunt area
and which is inhabited by all kinds of
strange creatures including plant
pygmies and animated trees you can see a
couple of them here and the module cover
each one of these new adventures is a
treasure hunt which means of course that
you win a guaranteed epic item if you
manage to beat it and we'll take a look
in more detail at valley of tears cowl
and what you win from it another one of
these videos if you've got further
through the campaign there are some much
harder adventures for you to try at
level 18 and these kick off with the
troll tyrant you can see up here now
each one of these adventures unlocks
more as I said there are six new
adventures in total three level 7 8 9 18
plus so here we are looking at the troll
tyrant know its features some classic
fantasy monsters
with a card hunter in interpretation of
them as well as that the epic items you
win from these high-level adventures are
these new artifacts the expansion is
steamed around and for beating the troll
tyrant you win this epic staff wall and
wall has a whole bunch of cards you
might not have seen before one of the
more interesting things about these
artifacts is there intelligent weapons
and that means they tend to be a little
bit impetuous so you can see for example
this impetuous blast card here would you
have to take if you take this item in
your loadout and it's an attack card
which is a trait it's the first time
we've done that kind of card it's a cut
so it's a quite a nice attack but you
have to play it when you draw it which
can sometimes be a little bit of a
problem depending on timing anyway well
like I said well we'll take a bit more
of a look at those adventures in more
detail as well as the new adventures of
course there's a ton of new cards and
items and the expansion set and let's
just have a quick look at some of those
the there's a new filter and the deck
builder we can toggle to only see these
new items you can see a whole bunch of
them here if you want to get these new
items they will drop in the regular
adventures and multiplayer but you can
also there's a bunch of chests that
we've created which are guaranteed to
contain at least one of the leaf one
item from the new set so there are there
are a bunch of different ways to get
hold of them some of the more
interesting items I'll just take a look
at now we've obviously tried to
introduce a whole lot of new mechanics
and new ways you to get invited over
your enemies whether they're in in the
campaign or in multiplayer and I'll just
take a look at a few the new mechanics
and talk quickly about why we might have
introduced some of them we try to
address some areas where we think
the game is not very well supported in
in the in the original set for example
we think that elves need to need a bit
of love they are at least play race and
multiplayer and people struggle with
them a bit in the campaign - so let's
just take a look at some of the new
cards that we've added for elves we've
you know tried to stay on theme with
olds which is that they are generally
about movement and trickery and less
about having a lot of health or you know
being tanks so one of the more powerful
cards I think is this new card elven
trickery which is a movement card with
the very special ability that if you end
this move adjacent to an enemy that
enemy discards all melee attack cards so
in other words here in elf you can run
up to your dwarven warrior opponent and
force him to throw out his entire hand
of attacks and then of course you can
just beat on him at your leisure so
that's an extremely powerful ability in
something we think will be in very high
demand there's there are some other
alpha bilities mixed in here as well
that you might not have seen before
I really definitely wouldn't have seen
before we haven't played the expansion
on the test server but let's let's
quickly have a look at that a few other
things in this set one of the other
areas that we think has been a little
bit neglected is in in in the wizard
suite of cards Wizards of course have
access to a lot of different abilities
including terrain manipulation and
pushing people around but they also do
damage and there's quite a few burning
cards in the wizard suite which caused
damage over time and those have tend to
be a little bit neglected - and one of
the reasons is that burning like this
flames for example here does a small
amount of damage over several rounds and
of course if your opponent's wearing
armor that can be a bit of a problem
because they find it easy to shrug off
small amounts of damage so we've added
this new
hot flames trait which when ensures that
whenever you're burning cards do damage
they penetrate any armor so we think
that that might have a good chance of
getting burning to be a little more
useful ability and finally let's let's
take a look at a an interesting new
ability which we've provided for both
from warriors Wizards and priests is
it's an interesting ability for both a
campaign and for multiplayer and it's
called the punishing the punishing
ability it's not keyword but the
punishing strike for example is the
warrior version of this card and
punishing basically is an ability that
increases the amount of damage that you
do based on how many cards or targets
holding now of course that's interesting
because some strategies are based around
drawing lots of cards and this is
something that really punishes your
opponent for being overly enthusiastic
was stocking their hand with cards so
for example punishing strike only does 3
base damage but it adds to damage for
every card and the targets hand so if
your opponent's kept two cards from last
round drawn three more and then maybe
stocked up on a couple more cards for
inspiration or some other form of card
draw you might have six or seven cards
in their hand and if you can let loose a
punishing stroke at the beginning of the
round you're gonna do maybe fifteen
seventeen points of damage which is
incredible for a silver card like that
so we think punishes an interesting
ability so as I said there's a there's a
lot of new items in the set you can you
can see a bunch of them here and we hope
you have fun you know checking them out
as you collect them playing through the
game like I said the items are all
available you know without paying a cent
just through playing through the regular
single-player content or through the
multiplayer as well as said as you might
have seen when I was
poking around on the chest shop before
there were a bunch of new figures in the
game so there's a complete set one for
each new race class combination here for
example is the health warrior because
also was dwarf warrior human warrior and
they're all a got a kind of an Aztec
theme to them so if you're interested in
that kind of look for your characters
that's we've introduced a whole bunch of
new looks that you can apply in campaign
multiplayer and speaking of multiplayer
one other very exciting feature that
we're adding to the game is multiplayer
leagues quail eggs are the first
official multiplayer tournaments that
we've added and I'm going to do another
video where I show how League works in
some detail and Ben and I will play a
battle in the league but basically
leagues are organized competitions with
prizes there are two types of leagues
this what I'm looking at here now is
what we call a fixed deck League and the
cool thing about them is we build the
decks for you you get a bunch of
characters to use in this case you're
actually playing some monsters and
everybody in that league uses the same
sort of decks and characters and lets us
set up some kind of interesting
situations and let you play with cards
and abilities that you might not
otherwise experience there are
constructed leagues as well where you
bring your own deck as usual so leagues
will run for a fixed period of time and
during that time you play other people
in the league and at the end of the
league
depending on how you've scored you'll
win some cool prizes so here for example
is a detailed description of this
particular league with the board that
will be used for it and a list of all
the prizes so you can win gold Pizza you
can win
you can even win figures that are not
otherwise available so meter we think
are a lot of fun and we're looking
forward to creating a whole bunch of
interesting scenarios and and playing
them so in any event that's a brief
overview of attack of the artifacts all
of the content that the new chests the
new figures are all available for
purchase within the game using pizza or
if you like we've put together a bundle
which is kind of similar to the basic
addition you might have seen and it
includes some of the adventures one of
the adventures is free the other five
costs a pizza or you can get them in
this bundle the bundle also contains a
month of club membership which gives you
the extra items when you open a chest it
contains all nine of the new Aztec
themed figures and three magnificent
artifact chests which should guaranteed
to contain a rare item from the
expansion set and that will be available
for $15 once we release
speaking of which we will be releasing
very soon sometime this month we don't
have an exact date yet but so definitely
the next couple of weeks and stay tuned
for more previews where I'm going to
play through some of the content and
show you some of the new cards in more
detail and how the leagues work and in
our first week after we launch you'll
get a free artifact chest which contains
an artifact item just for logging on
every day during that week and also
we'll be running a bunch of free leagues
so we'll let you know on our website on
our forums Twitter feed and also through
email if you've subscribed when the
expansion launches and we look forward
to seeing you online and showing you a
bit more as we roll out some more
previews thanks